brought you a little gift I thought
because you've been such an important
part of the show it's a it's a Swiss
Army knife that says big PS I always
called it n kiss when we start it so
that's the big kiss I appreciate that
and you know the thing about seeing you
at NCIS is I always would get a little
nervous for your interviews because I
never knew where we were going oh yeah
round two here we go Frasier come on
what you got his NCIS co-stars are his
family so why is he walking away why not
do this forever
the character had to leave at some point
I should have left years ago but I was
having so much fun I overstayed my
welcome horribly like that guest who
won't leave and keep digging into your
fridge give it up oh well he's leaving
behind some of the craziest moments
we've ever seen but we met him way back
before NCIS in 1994 he was a 25 year old
rocker he was in a band but his daytime
gig was as a soap opera star on loving
morning Entertainment Tonight or good
night Entertainment Tonight that young
guy he's visited our set a bunch of
times and I think Mary Hart will never
forget this it's an Entertainment
Tonight like you've never seen it before
Mary minxie I promise not to turn around
cuz I have a bird's-eye view get out of
there
Mary that was not the first time he got
a little racy they were a gift you got
to really just do it without that oh my
gosh that's hi this is Michael Weatherly
and you're watching but what are we
watching I don't you're watching Playboy
TV all I can say about that is that if
you think about it the most fun we have
in life is with our pants down and so I
I just feel like if if you want to feel
good get those pants off and see what
happens don't know if I agree with you
there Michael but I do know NCIS won't
be the same without Special Agent Gibbs
torturing don't need to know something
will you miss Harmon will you miss
making it back of the head will you miss
I won't miss the head slap we had a good
decade of that and I think I had my fill
when will you go back for a reunion or a
visit I'm kind of curious about where
we're NCIS goes next as a franchisee and
if DiNozzo were to be a part of that
deep space exploration I'm all for the
I'm all for the missions but for the
time being I'm gonna collapse into a
heap I'm gonna watch a lot of golf man
after my own heart went down yeah but
added up I believe he's just gonna be
watching golf because listen to this
Michael is actually working with dr.
Phil on a new TV drama for CBS based on
dr. Phil's younger days it's a trial I'm
on top of it by the way I like I do
you